hey everyone my name is Sam beef and I'm
a developer advocate at Google today
I'll be bringing you some quick tips to
get started with Google compute engine
setting up your Google cloud platform
account Before we jump into doing things
let's set up your account if you already
have one you can just skip forward the
first thing you need is a Google account
if you use Gmail Google+ YouTube or
Android you already have one of these
when you sign up for the trial it'll ask
you for credit card information but we
won't charge you unless you upgrade your
account and don't worry about your code
we automatically pause through your
account after the free trial is over
so you can upgrade when you're ready you
can see the free trial page for more
information
using the cloud launcher to quickly
deploy WordPress so you want to get your
website up and running fast the best way
to do this is to use the cloud launcher
here you can select pre-configured
images and launch them in just a few
clicks let's go to cloud Google com to
get started make sure you are logged in
to your Google account if you can see
your picture and the my console link
you're good to go
now click the launcher link
welcome to the cloud launcher the
launcher has hundreds of pre-configured
images from Google and partners such as
bitNami that you can launch with just a
few clicks in our case we want to start
a wordpress website so we click on the
wordpress google click to deploy
solution here we can see typical cost
for the solution and what is included by
default it launches an n1 standard one
machine with an additional hundred
gigabytes of disk and the estimated
monthly cost is around $35 in 84 cents
using the pricing calculator to estimate
pricing before we keep going I'm going
to show you how you can customize your
estimate by using the pricing calculator
while the free trial makes it easy to
experiment until you find your perfect
solution it's a good idea to use the
pricing calculator to estimate your
costs this way you can create a
combination that works for you on
cloud.google.com click the pricing link
then click on get a custom quote here
you can play with different
configurations to get the setup that
fits your budget and needs for this
example I'm going to be hosting a small
website so I have one server
and I select the free operating system
and a g1 small instance type
this server is going to be running all
day all night so these numbers look good
so I'll select the g1 small instance
with 50 gigabytes of disk space the
monthly cost comes to around 18 dollars
and 35 cents
this looks great but remember it is only
an estimate and your actual cost can
vary now that we found the image we want
to deploy and the estimated costs it's
time to deploy it let's go back to the
cloud launcher and select the WordPress
image the first thing we want to do is
click get started now select the project
you want to deploy into or create a new
one I've already created one for this
example so I'm going to select that one
now we see the configuration page for
the Google click to deploy solutions the
configuration section will be customized
for that particular solution for
WordPress the options are rather
straightforward
I can change my zone if I want then I
select the g1 small instance like I
configured in the pricing section and
set the disk 250 gigabytes
then I type in my admin email I also
make sure that PHP myadmin is checked
once I click deploy WordPress the wheels
start turning as you can see
deployment can take around four to five
minutes to complete so I'm going to fast
forward this section after a few minutes
we can see our wordpress instance is up
and running configuring firewalls and
networks now that the instance is
running I'm going to show you how to
access it the first step is to configure
the firewall to allow HTTP traffic go to
cloud Google comm then select the my
console link select the project you're
working on
click compute compute engine and VM
instances
click the external IP and check enable
HTTP option
if you want to make some more complex
rules we had a visit the network section
click network on the side panel then
select the network you want to modify in
most cases you just need to modify the
default Network here we can see all the
rules for the whole default network you
may notice that HTTP rule we made is not
here and that is because that rule is
only for the specific machine if you
want all machines on the default Network
to expose port 80 this is the best place
to do it so let's set a firewall rule
and then call the rule HTTP then type
0.0.0.0 slash zero to allow anyone to
access our website and open up TCP port
80 which is the standard HTTP port click
create now all machines on the default
network have port 80 open
to delete a click to deploy deployment
go to your developer console go to the
manage section
and then go to deployments click the
trash icon to delete the deployment
while click the deploy is awesome and
includes a lot of pre-built stacks like
mean lamp lamp rails and all the bitNami
images sometimes you want to roll all
your own custom set up Google cloud
platform makes this easy to do before we
go any further I want to mention that
Google Cloud has an awesome command-line
interface and a rest interface that you
can use to create deploy and manage
pretty much anything on the platform
from VMs to storage to databases you can
see how this can make automation really
easy for this video
I'll be doing mostly everything from the
GUI but you might notice little
equivalent rest and command line links
down below so everything I'm doing can
be replicated via rest on command line
as well the first thing I'm going to do
is go to my console then I'll go to the
compute section and the VM instances
section now click create instance here
where you can see the config page and we
can give our instance a name and choose
a zone it's a good idea to choose a zone
that's close to your customers
then we can pick a machine-type pick the
right machine type for your workload I'm
going to pick an N one standard one to
start with now we choose the boot image
and disk you can see all the options we
offer from Debian to Windows server to
enterprise Red Hat Linux you can even
create your own image or use a previous
snapshot I like Ubuntu 1404 LTS so
that's what I'm going to use I also want
it to use an SSD disk which is much
faster although slightly more expensive
we can also open the HTTP and HTTPS
ports right here saving us a trip to the
network section at this point we can
create our VM but I want to talk about
the advanced optional settings if we had
a fleet of machines we can give each one
individual tags to categorize them you
can also specify a startup script that
will run on boot I like to setup a
script that installs docker and
automatically pulls and starts my
containers without having me to type
anything in the disk section you can add
additional discs to your machine I
highly recommend creating a disk for
storing application data and not storing
your application data on the boot disk
in the network section you can choose if
you want a temporary IP address or a
static IP address the temporary address
will change every time you reboot your
machine while all the static address
stays the same and you can actually move
it between instances
I like the static addresses because it
makes configuring DNS and upgrading
machine types that much easier nope
you will be charged for unused static
addresses so make sure you use them if
you make them in the access and security
section you can add SSH keys and enable
access to other Google cloud platform
api's by default
now let's hit create and you can see it
chugging away in the background in a few
seconds and I'm serious the VM is up and
running we can SSH into our box by
clicking the little SSH button if we
launch the Windows server we would get
an RDP option instead you can also
download an SSH key to use or if you've
installed the Google Cloud SDK that I
previously mentioned you can SSH
directly from there as well
now you can do anything you want with
your VM backups increasing disk capacity
and upgrading servers now that your
server is up and running and getting
popular it's important to know how to
backup your VM and upgrade it thankfully
Google compute engine makes it easy to
make a backup of your disk all you need
to do is go to the snapshot section
click create snapshot select the disk
and bam after a few seconds a snapshot
is created and using the rest or command
line interface you can easily automate
this process you can use this snapshot
to create new virtual machines or use it
to restore your server to a previous
state now let's look at how we can
upgrade a machine I want to do four
things one attach a new hundred gigabyte
disk for application data to grow this
new disk to 500 gigabytes three grow my
boot disk from 10 gigabytes to 50
gigabytes and four go from a one core
machine to a four core machine one
attach a new disk to a running instance
let's look at how we can attach a new
blank disk to a running instance click
the instance you want to attach the disk
to then go to the disk section
and select new disk
let's set it to use an empty image with
a hundred gigabytes of space
now that the disk is physically attached
to the VM we need to mount it for the
rest of the tutorial I'm going to be
running Linux commands on a bunch of
system these commands should work for
most Linux systems but your particular
machine might be a little different
SSH into the machine by clicking the SSH
button
then let's look at all the disks using
the LS block command here we can see our
boot disk sta-1
is mounted as the root directory we can
also see a new disk called s TB and
there's no mouth point let's fix that
first make a new directory to mount our
disk let's call it mount app data run
sudo make their mount app data to make
our new directory
then Google cloud platform provides a
script to automatically format the disk
and mount it run this command which will
format and mount the disk if the disk
was pre formatted we could use the
standard mount command here
once that is done we can run Ellis block
and see the disk is mounted
to increase the size of an attached data
disc let's say you want to increase the
application disk size from 100 gigabytes
to 500 gigabytes because your data is
growing first thing you want to do is
stop your server this will try to
perform a clean shutdown so you don't
lose any data that might be written to
the disk then create a snapshot of the
disk
after this is done go to the disk
section and create a new disk
and it's very important that you create
this new disk in the same zone as the VM
select the snapshot we just created and
set the size to 500 gigabytes
now let's go to the instances screen
click our server
remove the old disk from the instance
and attach the new one
now if you boot up your machine we can
run the else block command and the disk
is there we can mount it using the
following mount command
and if you run the D F - H command you
can see the disk space has not increased
it still says 100 gigabytes this is
because the snapshot be used is set to
the old disk size we need to resize a
partition to use the full 500 gigabytes
first unmount the drive with sudo you
mount mount app data while you
technically can resize a drive that's
currently mounted and is safer to
unmount the drive run sudo e - fsck - F
and the name of the dr ste b then run
sudo resize - FS and the name of the
drive again SD b after that is done run
the mount command again to remount your
drive
now you can see we get the full 500
gigabytes of disk and it only took four
commands easy
resize the boot disk and upgrade your
machine type in order to upgrade your
boot disk or upgrade your VM you need to
follow basically the same process this
process requires you to create a brand
new instance and delete the old one
first make sure your VM is stopped then
create a snapshot of the boot disk
then create a new disc using the
snapshot
make sure the zone and size are correct
now we need to delete the old instance
double-check that the snapshot and disk
are created because deletion is
permanent after this is done we need to
create a new instance to use this new
disk
let's select a fork or machine and use
the new disk we just created
remember to attach the old data discs as
well once the machine is created we need
to reuse our old static IP address so we
don't have to reconfigure any DNS
settings
go to the network section and select the
static IP address if you're starting
this video
for unused resources first let's look at
the instances page here look VMs to stop
your VM stuck
currently using but one to use in the
future this is like shutting down your
PC while you're not charged for stop VMs
remember that you are still paying for
the disk if you want to completely
remove the VM use the delete function by
default this will remove the VM and the
boot disk this action is permanent so if
you want to be safe make a snapshot of
your disk before deleting now let's see
how we can remove old disks and
snapshots if we go to the disk
you notice I can't delete
disks that are not attached can be
deleted by selecting the disk and
clicking delete
some disks like boot disks cannot be
unattached the only way to delete these
discs is to delete the VM as well
I hope you enjoyed this quick tutorial
on getting started with Google compute
engine I can't wait to see what you
build
you
you